He's like, "J-Stock thinks there's an infinite shit." No. Well,
kind of. Kind of. The whole point of the infinite r- machine
isn't that it allows infinite r- to happen. It's like, "Hey,
there's a harmful person who's continuously engaging in harmful
behavior, and there are people who are monetarily incentivized
to protect that person because they gain money from it." Right?
The funny thing about the infinite r- machine is it basically
got rebuilt, and it's now it's the infinite doxing machine. He
He turned the He took the destroyed infinite r- machine, and
he took the pieces, and he added like a and a 40K boomer, and
a person who got kicked in the head by a horse, and he turned
it into the infinite doxing
>> So, this is Junt Roar Gaming guy who's been hanging
out in some of these communities. He's made a couple of decent
videos.
Um Queenmu mentioned doing do me about something. I forget which
one it was. Let me take a look at his channel real quick. Queenmu
showed me one of his videos a while back. It must have been one
of the Willy Mac ones. Yeah, I have halfway through this one.
So, I saw one of his videos a while back. Got a new Nicholas
DeOrio video. Actually kind of popping off. Holy sh- 2.1K views
in 17 hours. That's really
Kind of popping off. Let's check it out. Okay, 40 41 minutes.
Damn. Let's go.
Throughout 2025, I've seen commentary streamer and video essayist
Nicholas DeOrio transition his content and behavior into something
totally unrecognizable for how it was in years past. I've seen
the quality of his content and analysis sharply decline as he
shies away from acknowledging any criticism that is levied against
him. In this video, I want to break down some of the ways that
Nicholas has abandoned his long-standing principles and show
how he is both willing to lie for his own personal benefit and
allow his friends to lie with little to no pushback.
Nicholas is jolly looking, okay?
Don't Don't mock him. He is jolly. Look, name a happier looking
person than Nicholas DeOrio, okay?
You can't.
>> What the [__] Chad baby? What the [__]
Chad baby? >> is that Nicholas has abandoned his long-
My most prominent criticisms of Nick come from his awful coverage
of Ethan Klein. Nick has done a complete 180 on his opinion of
the Kleins. He went from someone who would proudly call Hila
Klein horse face to someone who makes pathetic, groveling sympathy
posts for her plight as an Israeli living in the United States.
>> The first wave of like commentary channels that started
to hate us, Mhm.
they like to make a joke that I look like a horse. >> Joe
Rogan should give Hila back her
See, he tweets this, right? Ooh.
I was going to say, I didn't think I That didn't sound to me
like a joke Nicholas would make.
But apparently he was making that joke back in 2021. God damn.
And somehow you trended over what now? What was the story you
trended over on the H3 Reddit? Moses was being accused of assault.
Come on. The thread was was sh- and Nick for making fun of somebody's
looks, and here they are. Roly poly
small trolley.
>> on somebody's looks. That must have been when they sold
snarkers, okay? This must have been before they the H3 snarkers
broke off and made their own thing. Okay? They had some snarking
capability of their own. >> even need plastic surgery to
fix mine.
>> I just need like a diet and exercise. You need a They
need to call a surgeon to fix that >> Oh,
Nick. Nah, dude. starts tweeting a picture of a horse, and Ethan
adds his own context, which is driving him crazy. And And it's
funny because it's like a 10,000 IQ play. Hila goes, "Well, why
can't he just call me a horse?" The reason he can't call you
a horse is because your joke doesn't work.
>> There's like multiple comments I want to make here.
Boblox, Augie, Aiden, TommyC. Wow, what a cast. Augie's got a
Listen, far be it for me to, you know, as a VTuber to talk [__]
about people's appearances, but I love doing it cuz it does upset
people. Augie's got like a Megamind thing going on here. What's
What's happening with this? Is this like a It feels like a filter.
I usually see him with the hat on. What's going on?
What's What's happening? I flagged the tweet. NO, CUZ YOU'LL
PROBABLY FLAG THE TWEET. I don't think like using your platform
to attempt to deplatform someone is fair to me, and I'm Oh, [__]
Did AB on here? [__] So, if I want to tweet a off
horse emoji, you can hate me for it. You can think it's funny.
>> for it. That's why >> I I I brand myself as an
[__] I don't come on this internet to be liked by
people. participate in some really nasty stuff like calling Hila
horse face and stuff. >> I did do that. That being said,
water under the bridge. But I'm just saying there was a reason.
Yeah. But he thought that I wouldn't
forgive him or anything, but I
>> Now, Nick, tell us how beautiful this woman is, okay,
Nick?
Oh, Hila, your makeup is so well done. Hila, your makeup is so
beautiful.
You are radiant. You are glowing. Oh my god, are you pregnant
again? You are glowing,
>> I actually watch your content pretty regularly now.
I specifically s- I remember I'm like, "Why? I don't think any
of these p- I don't think like Hila Klein, I don't think Ethan
I don't I don't think anyone's going to Will we get Lav in here
for analysis? I'm not sure. We'll see. forgive me for any of
those comments or anything like that. I think he I really And
then she was watching the stream. I I like DeOrio. I got to say,
I got to admit it. I'm a DeOrio fan. So, I had tweeted support
for Hila Klein is pivotal right now. Look at the quote tweets.
All I did was tweet out like support for Hila Klein, which I
think is totally fine. I think you're a complete loser if you
have a problem with this tweet. Um Commentary YouTubers are a
waste of oxygen. Fat crying about the ugliest getting harassed.
Uh you know the world has to So, this will be basically when
when Hasan made the comment about how
It was basically saying that Hila would be a valid target technically.
He's talking about how you would be a valid
>> a valid military target doing certain
in Palestinian territory, and I think he basically extended that
up to Hila Klein when she was actually a a part of the to get
nuked cuz fat
Sorry, part of the IDF and you know, engaging in the night raid,
like on that night raid. YouTubers
think they deserve to live.
Support for the horse-faced
settler is pivotal right now. IDF sympath- There's not like a
single positive comment right now. Uh I'm a scientist now. Support
Eva Braun. She's Well, Hitler's wife. Okay, that's a good Uh
I Next one's for the ladies. >> Hila's makeup off about
to be done. You finally realize you've been late for a high-powered
business meeting. Only to realize you're not wearing makeup.
>> does her makeup? >> woman's nightmare. That's
why I invented this revolutionary makeup gun. It's for the woman
who only has 4/5 of a second to get ready. Close your eyes, Marge.
And now you're ready for a night on the
Oh, Marge, you've got it set on home.
Now, hold on. >> on the town. That's actually
That's not really that far off, is it? That seems like about
on the money.
That's like not that far off. Dude, [laughter] the blue is deep
here. >> goes. I think I actually
I It's not even like an exaggeration. The white is the the She
blends better,
He blends better. She blends better. I'll give her that.
Let's continue. [__] her, but that's as far as my
support goes.
You don't have to like her, but
uh we should never support a off evil genocidal freak. Uh all
you do is fuel anti-Semitism.
Jew, no thanks, bro.
So, look at all of the zero like comments. Definitely. All the
zero My favorites are the zero like comments. They show me what
people really think. When nobody engages with them and thinks
they're weird. That shows me what people really think, actually.
>> humbly unrepentant terrorist. I made a voodoo doll of
Hila. I'm giving it hugs and kisses to show my support.
Uh now you're She's a Hope she dies a horrible death.
Um you mean the raider of Ramallah, which was a
>> I mean, this is just like Uh we need the people to deal
with her. Only N-words and F-slurs care about
Yeah, I don't know. Yikes. Nick was one of Ethan Klein's biggest
critics back in 2020. He put out a multi-part video series strongly
criticizing Ethan for his unhinged behavior. But now, Nick will
stop at nothing to defend Ethan What was the unhinged behavior
that he called out? I actually don't recall. Well, I I probably
wasn't even following the sphere at all at that time, so
What was the behavior that Nick was calling out?
And does that be- behavior persist into the modern day? Is that
still a problem? And we all have to pretend that Ethan has changed
in some tremendous way. Do we even know who the night raid was
for? Could have been for a serial killer.
Literally could have been for Osama bin Laden. He was hiding
in Palestine
the whole time. They were trying to find
Could have been anyone.
This leads me to question of 2025 >> I think I think the
overall criticism there is that the raid almost certainly is
illegal by international law, right? Like there's there are there
are legality problems with the IDF express or, you know, carrying
out military operations
at certain places in certain time at certain times in certain
ways. I think mostly people question the the legitimacy, if not
the legality, then the legitimacy of Israel conducting those
operations in a general sense.
Right? If you want to say that against what state? Okay, there's
just like not a good place to go with the argument. Um actually,
they don't really represent a state. They're not recognized,
so you can't actually break international law against them. Probably
not a good one. why Ethan is really that different from 2020.
Let's look at some of the main criticisms that Nick used against
Ethan in his 2020 video series. Nick criticized Ethan heavily
for using Etika's death as a way to attack Keemstar in 2020.
>> Why does this dude's legacy need to be subjected to
this? Why does this dude's
need to be weaponized and debated on a year later in YouTube
drama exposed video? This just feels like a cop-out because he's
gone. He's unable to speak for himself. Etika is unable to interject
and let people know what he was feeling or pick a side. It's
an allegation that H3H3 felt comfortable to walk right up to
the door with because Etika's not here to tell him that's not
true and nobody knows exactly what was going through Etika's
mind. >> day, Ethan still regularly engages in this behavior.
Back in June, Kayla Rains, the Oh,
>> oh, no.
Stark This is the woman Stark, right?
This is obviously the woman Stark, I
I think, if I remember correctly. Is the fox lady? >> founder
of the Save a Fox wildlife initiative, took her own life due
to a combination of mental health issues and criticism that she
received both online and in real life regarding the way she ran
her animal sanctuary. Most of the online harassment she received
was from Kiwi Farms Tumblr and a very inactive snark subreddit,
which only had 19 posts in total at the time of her death. Even
Klein very quickly decided to make this woman's about himself,
claiming that her snark subreddit was the deciding factor in
her death and comparing it to his own snark subreddit, claiming
that their end goal is to get him to kill himself. In reality,
Michaela's death had very little, if anything, to do with her
tiny snark subreddit and likely had much more to do with the
harassment and criticism that she received What was the problem
people had with like having an awesome fenced-in yard of foxes?
Cute little foxes that prance about and play.
But what did What did people take issue with here? Feel like
abusing these animals? see from other sanctuaries in real life
in combination with her mental health struggles. This didn't
stop Ethan from turning the spotlight on himself in an effort
to remove criticism of himself from the internet. It would seem
like DiOrIo doesn't personally agree with the assessment that
Michaela's snark subreddit was the reason she killed >> So,
yeah, yeah, a girl save save a fox herself from on a snark sub.
It is crazy and yet Yeah, I just I completely disagree with this.
Reddit does nothing. And there is no account But despite boldly
disagreeing with Ethan on this over 6 months later, Nick still
has never addressed Ethan weaponizing this woman's death to build
Guys, I disagree with this, but listen, H3 snarkers are really
bad dudes. You guys ever think about how H3 snarkers are really
bad? And if I criticize Ethan when he is being snarked, then
wouldn't I be myself a snarker?
If I said that I disagree with this and if I said Ethan's wrong
on this, he should stop doing this. It's actually wrong that
he's even doing this in the first place. If
Wait, hold on. First I should say I should back it up and I should
say Has he Has Nick really never said that? I disagree with this.
Obviously, it was wrong to do like for him to try to like weaponize
this in this way.
Did he say that this time? Cuz I I assume he did, actually.
I would absolutely assume that Nick would say, "No, Ethan, it's
actually wrong for you to do this. You need to stop doing this.
This is totally This is the kind of thing that will get the public
against you. It will turn the public against you. Don't try to
just weaponize every single thing that happens and turn it into
your drama. It will make people hate you."
That's what like a friend would say, right? If you weren't just
like
totally, I guess, like with blinders on, sighted in on just the
dollar signs, right? Maximizing dollar signs. You'd probably
tell your friend like, "Hey, don't do this, man. It's probably
a bad idea." bolster his campaign to remove his detractor base
from the internet. Ethan Klein even made Charlie Kirk's death
about himself. Within hours of Kirk's shooting, Ethan was posting
Instagram stories blaming websites like Twitch for the shooting
and saying that he feels unsafe due to Mike from PA of all people.
Ethan will dig up any corpse that he can and make anyone's death
about himself to get the upper hand over his enemies. In 2020,
DiOrIo was so critical of this behavior that he included a full
Etika tribute in his video, but now he won't even address Ethan's
participation in this same behavior. Nick also heavily and rightfully
criticized Ethan for starting a trend of going after an enemy's
sponsors online. In 2020, Ethan went after Keemstar's G Fuel
sponsorship and ended up getting him dropped from the company.
In retaliation, Ethan claimed to have lost about 80% of his podcast
sponsors. Nick said that he didn't support the sponsor war, but
felt no sympathy for Ethan starting them. He's apparently lost
80% of his own sponsors for the H3 podcast. Now, to be clear,
nobody is sure if this is partially due to COVID or 100% in relation
to his attacks on channel sponsors in May, but regardless, it's
a clear case of karma rearing its head. I'm not one to celebrate
money being pulled out of a creator's pockets, but I also don't
really have sympathy or empathy for those who have made the statements
Ethan has made and can
Now, I will say
Here is Nick.
Once again
not standing on his principles.
I'll just say for the people who You got to call it out every
time, right? This is This is evidence he wasn't standing on his
principles a long time ago, actually. Right? He's doing the exact
same thing he did with the DMCA stuff. With regards to H3 snark.
Well, yeah, sure. Ethan's like disingenuously DMCA-ing clips,
sure, but like I don't feel bad for the snarkers, right? It's
his way of of avoiding calling out something wrong happening
that he thinks is wrong.
I guess, in this case, it's a little different because there's
no snarker. It's like a a one-to-one comparison, right? Instead
of the totally like
uh what would you call it? Like um asymmetric relationship of
a snarker who's clipping Ethan to Ethan himself.
Like this is Keemstar and Ethan's communities going back and
forth, I would assume. There's less of a less of a way you can
say, "Well, I need to stand on principle and tell somebody else
not to do this, right?" Like that exact thing is happening to
them. You would assume. Maybe it's a little different. I just
I thought it was interesting cuz I've heard criticism of Nick
for the DMCA-ing thing, right? When when Ethan DMCA's uh you
know, creators or just people he decides are snarkers. When he
DMCA's them and Nick goes, "Well, I'm usually against using DMCA's
like a weapon just to get like just to avoid criticism, but in
this case, I don't feel bad cuz snarkers suck."
Right? It's a very similar tack he's taking here between these
two things. >> to make. Ethan still engages in this behavior
except today he goes after Twitch's sponsors directly.
So, anyway, cat Shout-out to Cap- Capcom.
Sh- Ethan did a DMCA? I believe that's how he got several clips
taken down from H3 snark. Was he literally DMCA-ing them? No?
I believe this is the case. Evron and Samsung, who are proudly
displayed on the backdrop of this panel, in which um
to Israeli hummus brand
I perceive as Zionist or
>> um Arab to tier list
being enjoyed here in front of Chevron,
Capcom, and Samsung proudly sponsored in collaboration with Twitch.
Awesome.
I would argue that this is much worse because targeting these
website-wide sponsors could impact many more innocent creators
who just so happen to use the website and have nothing You don't
say. If only somebody had brought this up to them at the time.
Like Nicholas himself. If only If only someone like Nicholas
had said, "Hey, this is going to cause like some splash on other
people." Didn't Nicholas say this precisely to Dan? I could have
sworn if this wasn't in tweets, it was in like a stream or something
where Nicholas is like, "Oh, you shouldn't do this. It could
actually cascade to the rest of the site and you'll [__]
over a whole bunch of other creators."
Could have sworn he said it to Dan over this exact same issue.
Did he ever make this criticism of Ethan Klein? to do with the
perceived anti-Semitism that Ethan is saying. Now, you would
assume that Nicholas, who previously was so principally opposed
to Ethan starting a sponsor war against Keem, would be pretty
appalled by this. Well, in reality, he said that Ethan's actions
were probably wrong, but ultimately excused them because of the
Arab to tier list. I'm sorry, dude. You can get mad at Dan.
Who this? Hello. Snarker.
Oh, what's up?
Hold on. I
I was actually I want a makeup review. How Can we get a makeup
review? Oh my
>> I think that Ela is very beautiful. I don't think There's
different types of There's cute.
There's hot and there's beautiful.
I don't think she's cute.
I don't think she's hot. But I do think she's beautiful.
>> She's also
aging. Um Hm. And because of that, your makeup has to change
a little
I often see Ela dress and do her makeup like a zoomer.
And it's not doing her any favors. Keep going. I need to I forgot
I need to get you to go after a man's looks as well really quick
somewhere because somebody came into my Discord who was super
upset about how misogynist I was for letting you rail on Nexpo
Arcadate's makeup. When I feel like you were probably trying
not to be a dick about it. But I don't think I was being
bri- I literally was saying how beautiful she was, just that
she needs to change her makeup. Like that was That was the vibe.
Um and everyone was like, "Oh, good troll." And I like was not
trolling. Um But yeah. If If the What about About Okay, here
we About Ela.
the makeup she's wearing Go ahead. Sorry. I'm Go ahead and tell
me how Ela is beautiful again. Yeah, I think she's beautiful.
I think she has very bright blue eyes, contrasting features.
She has a bit of a a long mid-face.
Um but that's like the only thing that like is wrong with her.
Other than that, she has like You got to like >> very pretty
features.
You got to like pick a spirit animal for somebody with like a
long mid-face.
What would it be?
Obviously, it's a horse, but I don't
There's a beautiful >> watching the stream, you came to
that determination just from nothing but visual indicators? What
do you mean? There There are beautiful horse-faced women out
there. Sure. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. But I'm just saying
that Listen, there's a bit of a moment in this video earlier
where they Somebody, namely Nicholas DiOrIo, may have called
her horse-faced
I just wanted to make sure you didn't see that part of the clip
and you're you're not you know, riffing off of
Uh no, of course I didn't see that part of the clip. I don't
watch your streams. Okay, fair enough. >> I'm going to
pee while I talk to you about her makeup. Um
Go ahead.
Um so sorry if you hear it, but uh yeah, other than I love when
she wears like a smokey eye. I think that a smokey eye is cool
on her, but the eyeshadow is like not the move. Can you play
a little bit of the clip so I can get a better
You watch your content pretty regularly >> I specifically
I remember I'm like why now hold on. Yeah, it's and some really
nasty stuff like calling Ela horse-faced and stuff. >> I
did do that. That being said, water under the bridge, but I'm
just saying there was a reason. >> Yeah, but he thought
that I wouldn't um forgive him or anything, but I actually watch
your content pretty regularly now. I specifically I remember
I'm like why I don't think any of these I don't think I can't
listen to Nicholas DeOrio's voice. Please stop it. Um also Nicholas
DeOrio hit me so
And then she was watching the stream.
You don't need to keep playing it. I was giving a makeup breakdown.
Uh I do have to keep playing it. Sorry. leave with the makeup
breakdown after the makeup breakdown. Um on like a on like a
21-year-old
woman, this look would be really really cute, but on a mature
face
it looks kind of strange and out of place. But with just a smokey
eye, it would be really cute. I think Ela's very beautiful. I've
always thought that she was very beautiful.
yeah, I think that if I remember correctly, the picture of
that Ethan's dad was off to, look pretty hot in that, right?
I think. Oh my god.
Sorry. [laughter] Yeah, I mean now that I'm looking at it, her
mid face is not like crazy long. She has good angles and bad
angles like everyone. But
I mean she's like obviously like a good How old is she? Isn't
she in like her mid 40s?
I don't know. I Mm. Yeah, she's had babies. She's in her mid
40s. Like she's doing her thing. She's doing her job. She's a
business owner. She's an artist. Like
uh mid to late 30s,
not mid 40s.
>> Well, mid to late 30s. She's a mother. She's an artist.
She's a business owner.
Like she's
you know, she's doing her thing.
Wow, yeah. Look at the the the picture of her in that pink dress.
Like yeah, she looks great. Yeah, that's that's better look,
for sure.
Yeah, she looks great. So I Is she like the hottest woman in
the world?
She doesn't have to be. Not every woman you see has to be the
hottest woman in the world. That blue eyeshadow with the blue
eyes has to be a horrible mistake,
Well, it is when you're when you have mature skin. It robs all
of the contrast out of your out of your eyes. When you have mature
skin, that's true. If she was younger, it'd be like a very cool
Y2K
look, but but your makeup has to change as you age. I can't do
the same makeup I did when I was 20. 30s are rough. It is what
it is.
We we age. We get older. We do.
>> That's tough. And All right. Any other >> Yeah.
Um yeah, you wanted me to be mean about a man. I think um Ethan
is um haggard. I think he's
This is I I actually think he looks with this much weight. I
legitimately think he looked better with like a little bit of
the weight. I think he's gotten like too skinny. Like he's looking
like hollow.
He is like a lot.
Yeah, I don't know if he's I just >> Addams thing going
on here and now he's like too skinny. >> does. They do
kind of look like hype beast Gomez and Morticia. I kind of love
that for them actually. I kind of love
Not everyone you see has to be the most attractive person in
the world. It's okay to just be like
They're attractive people. Like they're not butt ugly, you know
what I mean? So they're fine.
Yeah, they're not like, you know, Nicholas DeOrio.
I think Ela's got the kind of face that you can easily call ugly.
But I don't think she's like Yeah, I but I think it's just because
she has unique features. She's obviously not actually ugly.
And like I said, she's not cute. She's not hot, but she is beautiful,
I think. It's like a unique beautiful. She's striking. Full body
shot.
Anyway, thank thanks for having me on. Always appreciate
Thank you for coming on. See you later. Bye. All right, let us
continue.
The infamous hummus panel. You can get mad at Ethan and most
of it's justified. Hold on, I'm going to pull it back just a
little bit here. >> He said that Ethan's actions were probably
wrong, but ultimately excused them because of the Arab to Jew
tier list. I'm sorry, dude. You can get mad at Dan. You can get
mad at Ethan and most of it's justified, I guess, about going
after sponsors, but don't forget that Twitch had an Arab to Jew
tier list. I'm sorry, but there's never been anything like this.
This isn't comparable to PewDiePie on YouTube. Twitch let them
host The virtue signaling over this is so [__] >> an
Arab to Jew tier list in front of five [__] sponsors
on the wall at their own convention and then had to get bullied
by social media into [__] enforcing their own [__]
terms of service. Wasn't it months later when when people actually
picked it up? I feel like it wasn't like right at TwitchCon,
right? When did we when did we all pick it up and like start
talking about it? I feel like it was way later.
I was willing to celebrate those people getting banned cuz I
was on my those people moment, but I didn't I didn't go
and hand ringing. In fact, I believe I told everybody who came
on to hand ring about this tier list that they were being histrionic
in different words, okay? It was just like, come on, man. That's
not really that bad.
He provided no commentary about the potential blowback that starting
an adpocalypse level sponsor war against Twitch could cause for
innocent creators and actually quickly segued into a segment
about Mia Khalifa. Chevron, Capcom, and Samsung.
Do you know
that there is an Arab to Jew tier list happening in It is. It
literally is an Arab to Jew tier list.
Dude, could you imagine it's like hard R to honky tier list.
Dude, I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I watched this clip and I'm like,
what the [__] am I actually watching? This is This
is mad. I need to say something. >> Dude, this is legitimately
a totally reasonable reaction to the [__] you're
seeing. People are saying this is Ethan's crash out. Have you
read any of the Reddit posts or seen any of the tweets from this
community? If you're insulated in like my sector or you're looking
at any of his stuff, go to the Hasan [__] subreddit
and just Don't go look at what Hasan [__] says. Go
to the Hasan [__] subreddit.
Guys, when I'm going to criticize someone, I'm going to criticize
the behavior of some random who isn't the person I'm criticizing
or the or even like even a creator in the community I'm criticizing.
I'm going to criticize their Reddit posters. Okay? But also,
if you criticize anyone around me, I'm not responsible for them.
Will he max lying about all these people and I retweeted his
video? I'm not responsible for that. I'm not responsible. Come
on, guys. I'm not responsible.
Don't hold me responsible for that.
That's his own guy. He's his own guy. I'm not responsible for
that at all. Do a scroll. Even today, you're not too late. You'll
see a bunch of people total
Yeah, joke. people acting like this this is their literal personal
9/11.
Um so they are very in touch with the
so we're going to have to ask them. Wait, what?
>> What is Buntly King doing? No way.
way, dude. Holy [__]
Pull this up for a second. We'll get there. We'll get to that.
I got to pull up Mia Khalifa, all right? Speaking of professional
on a screen, pull up Mia Khalifa right now. Mrs. PTSD from This
is one instance of a trend where Nick refuses to engage with
criticism that he knows he cannot defend. He even admits that
Ethan is mostly wrong in his call out of sponsors, but still
searches for a way to downplay any potential criticisms due to
the perceived anti-Semitism from Twitch. A big point of contention
in Nick's second 2020 video on Ethan was that Ethan platformed
and legitimized the creator BritBongReturns. BritBong was a serial
deplatformer, doxxer, swatter, and someone who would routinely
fill Discord servers and DMs with illegal material. Now, while
I do believe that BritBongReturns is a much more detestable online
figure for doing things like spamming AidenUnderground and AugieRFC's
DMs with illegal material, a comparison can be made in the sense
that Ethan still works with unhinged degenerates like DanSaltman.
DanSaltman [clears throat] is a doxxer Wait, what? Hold on. I
don't have my I don't have my stream deck up. I didn't get to
hear that. I think you guys heard
Wait, what? That's crazy.
doing things like spamming AidenUnderground and AugieRFC's DMs
with illegal material, a comparison can be made in the sense
that Ethan still works with unhinged degenerates like DanSaltman.
DanSaltman is a doxxer, doxxer, liar, and deplatformer who will
stop at nothing to get Hasan deplatformed from Twitch and Dan
Clancy fired as their CEO. He's doxxed Hasan
I'll I'll call out when this guy lies, okay? moderators There's
one of Hasan's moderators, the guy named Comrade Lamb.
And uh he's been on his account
calling me a um and I just I did a
subpoena and got his information, his full information. I'm going
to
you know, it was quick, surprisingly. Wait, really? You can just
do that? Yep. Stop. No. >> It's blatant. No, you don't
do that [__] on my stream. Going after Twitch's sponsors
to Uh-oh. try to start his own adpocalypse and gone as far as
to contact the mainstream media and politicians in his crusade.
Ethan proudly displays a redact.dev sponsorship, which is Dan's
company, on all of his livestreams and is in constant communication
with Dan behind the scenes. Ethan doesn't just platform these
degenerates, he now That was So, the text said he read the the
full name He said the full name. I do believe he said the full
name and not nothing else. Dude, the text says here again. >> mention
his full information Just do that? Don't do that [__]
on my
Says full name and state. Oh, full name and state, right. Stop.
No. his own adpocalypse Now, there is some sweeping you could
do there, okay?
There's There's some sweeping you could do about like that guy
but I Listen, that's that's Dan's job, >> pocalypse and
gone as far as to contact the mainstream media and politicians
in his crusade. Ethan proudly displays a redact.dev sponsorship,
which is Dan's company, on all of his livestreams and is in constant
communication with Dan behind the scenes. Ethan doesn't just
platform these degenerates, he now takes sponsorship money and
endorses these people. Again, I'm not saying that Dan is as bad
as Britbong, but any person who's principally opposed to Ethan
legitimizing Britbong should also be opposed to collab- Dan's
really smart, though. Dan is basically running
the version
of like a coffee company, okay? You know how the conservatives
have their coffee company that they try to rile you into buying
buying like coffee from explicitly
by like moralizing the fact that you should buy the coffee. Dan's
doing the same thing, but for privacy software. He's like the
great defender. He's going to defend all the people. He's going
to attack anybody who does anti-semitism, and you should support
redact.dev
because of that.
You could go get multiple extensions that delete and save your
Discord logs, but why would you do that when you can go get redact.dev
and support a proud
You know?
You know? collaborating with Dan, but the Oreo couldn't care
Except Redact is useful to the community, unlike coffee.
Do you think Redact sells Do you think more people have use for
Redact than coffee? I don't know I don't know if you know this.
Coffee's pretty popular beverage. A lot of people drink coffee.
If they can help like somebody they like by paying an extra five
bucks to get the same coffee through their company,
wouldn't that make sense? And Lesson has even platformed Dan
himself at times. Nick, instead of condemning Ethan for working
with Dan, will routinely use him as a scapegoat to write off
many of Ethan Klein's criticisms. If Ethan says anything that
is blatantly false or accuses Hasan of something out of context,
it's always Dan's fault for feeding him misinformation. Ethan
can never just be wrong or malicious in his framing of his enemies.
There's also the elephant in the room of Ethan Klein's malicious
lawsuits. It's no secret that I am principally opposed to these
lawsuits. I find it ridiculous that any so-called commentator
would think of supporting them. These lawsuits are built upon
a lie that Ethan needs to defend his copyright and are being
used as a political weapon to silence Ethan's critics. And in
the I think the lie is that he wants to defend his copyright
or that he was upset that his copyright is being violated by
these people. He explicitly wanted them to violate his
That was his plan. That was the whole goal. case of the H3 snark
moderators, these lawsuits are being used as an attempt to dox
their private identities and an attempt to scare away future
criticism. Ethan has expressly stated that he wants to reveal
the identities of the snark moderators to their families, schools,
and jobs, essentially doxing them and participating in life ruination.
His orbiters will use the skulls and CPS call as a way to deflect
away from this unhinged behavior as if it is some sort of get
out of jail free card that allows Ethan to do literally whatever
he wants forever. Ethan has even outright lied Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. They don't like They don't just pull
that out all the time as if it's like a trump card, right? They
skulls or CPS Surely, every time you have a criticism of Ethan
Klein, it wouldn't be met with "Dude, they called CPS." I don't
I don't think you could possibly argue that they do that every
single
time. Soapbox literally doesn't get it, but it's fine.
>> Dan is legal No, Soapbox, I do know that they do that
every single time. That's why I'm making the point.
Sorry. We're We're continuing. incorrectly claiming that one
of the snark users was a mod that was collaborating with Denims
to steal his copyright. In reality, this was just a regular subreddit
user who sent Denims a DM expressing that she should stream a
reaction to the content nuke to avoid giving Ethan views. She
never even responded to this message. Literally anyone can message
Denims on Twitter, Instagram, her Twitch chat, and I guess if
you really want to spend 20 Literally anyone can message Denims
on Twitter,
I need to speak to Stark. Okay. her Twitch chat, and I guess
if you really want to spend $20, you can message her on OnlyFans
or Fansly. There's no guarantee that she will respond to any
of these messages, but anyone can try to get in contact with
her. Again, this is an instance of Nicholas blatantly downplaying
and not engaging with criticism against Ethan Klein. He claimed
that he would look into this if it was a lie, but then never
ended up following up. >> I think it's the Dan Saltman
tweet is the important one.
The what? This is true. I have message from Someone take a picture
of this stuff on the screen. Someone take a picture of this.
I don't know if this is actually a moderator. It seems like preliminary
reporting is yeah, this is an H3 snark moderator. I don't know
who this Dartis guy is, and I don't know how they got that information.
I just saw Keemstar's tweet on Nicholas DeOreo. Keemstar's appreciated
the shout-out. Does anyone know the lore behind this person?
I feel like if this is real, like not that like
if it's real cuz it's from the law- Wait, now I need a timeline.
Do we have a timeline here? Was this before it was shown in the
counter-filings that this person was not a mod?
Cuz they claimed he was a mod the whole time. How did Nicholas
just go "Whoa, whoa, whoa"? Do we know that this guy's a mod?
Was it before or after? I actually want to know.
When did he When did he make these comments? I just saw I need
to hear that again. Dan Saltman tweet is the important one. I
don't know if this is actually a moderator. It seems like preliminary
reporting is yeah, this is
I don't know if it's actually a moderator. Preliminary reporting.
No, it's not preliminary reporting.
This is Dan actually faithfully representing what's in the document,
shockingly. Is Nick trying to like say "Oh, I don't know if this
reporting is accurate" when it's Dan just saying what's in the
document?
The liar here wouldn't be Dan. The liar here would be Ethan and
his lawyers. They would be the liars. So, just to be clear, he's
going like "Oh, I don't know if this is I don't know if the reporting
is accurate." No, the reporting doesn't
On January 21st, 2025, the H3 snark mod with the Discord name
Dartosis sent Denims a direct message on Discord. This isn't
This is Dan just saying what's in the document from Ethan's lawyers
that they filed. This is in a motion. This is an H3 snark moderator.
I don't know if who this Dartis guy is, and I don't know how
they got that information.
I just saw Keemstar's tweet on Nicholas DeOreo. Keemstar's appreciated
the shout-out. Does anyone know the lore behind this person?
I feel like if this is real, like not that like
>> if it's real cuz it's from the lawsuit. If this is actually
a mod-
If this is real cuz it's from the law- He's like He was just
blaming Dan and now he goes "Well, it's I guess it's from the
lawsuit now that I've read." >> moderator, and that's actually
the Discord tied to the moderator. This is really bad for them.
Still wouldn't be really bad unless Denims engaged in some way
with those
right? Coordination requires her to reciprocate in some way.
She doesn't reciprocate. You don't even know that she saw it.
You have no idea, right? >> This would be really bad for
them.
If this If this were real If this were
it would be really bad. Why? Cuz a person sent her a DM that
you can't her see her acknowledging that she gave you
There is no response to? But that's really bad. That'd be like
really bad, actually. That'd be like really bad. This is like
either absolutely nothing or a complete and total nuke.
I I it
That's Maybe that is Is that not like the worst part of this
for Nicholas? Is that he seems to have actually lost his ability
to analyze things correctly. Like Like it's not just that he's
totally disingenuously presenting one side of the narrative to
help one side and thereby milk money out of that side. That's
already pretty bad, but he's also even when he's trying to be
good faith, he is
Like he is saying something totally stupid here. Now, I'll say
the old Nick the old Nick that I knew, okay? If he said something
completely
Usually, he'd roll it back a little bit. He'd go and he'd figure
out where he said something dumb. He'd see a message in chat.
He'd like kind of walk it back slightly. Let's see if this Nick's
If If that If that's a Reddit moderator that's If that's a snark
moderator, this is absolutely
worst-case scenario for Denims and them,
Like that is actually crazy.
They're completely deluded in their little bubble.
I've heard privately from people, and I'm not going to name any
names. They're They're skeptical about this. So, I'm proceeding
with caution. Wait, who's skeptical about it?
Surely Well, it can't be Hold on. It literally can't be Hold
on. What do you mean they're skeptical?
Who could you have heard something skeptical about the Who Who
could have been skeptical of this? I don't understand.
Probably Augie. No, no, no, no, no. Who could have had reason
to doubt this? I read this and I'm like what's their like reason
for saying it? I don't trust them cuz I think Ethan Klein is
a liar. But if you don't think Ethan Klein's a liar, you don't
think this is Ethan Klein
right? Then obviously they'd have some evidence for this.
Surely they wouldn't just present something, say it's fact, and
be lying,
But then he says, "Well, privately, well, who the [__]
you talk to privately that doesn't think this is true, that has
some reason to believe it's not
If not the clients themselves.
But I mean that's that that would be crazy if it turns out to
be fully accurate. These lawsuits were never really about copyright.
Even Nicholas has openly admitted this on Discord. Nick has outright
stated that it would be delusional to think that these lawsuits
are exclusively about protecting copyright. But he still has
no problem supporting Ethan's blatant lies that he is simply
trying to save the YouTube space from content thief reactors
that all just so happened to provide harsh criticism of his political
takes on the Israel and Palestine situation. Nick has [clears throat]
perfectly fallen in line with Ethan's attempt to brand his detractor
base as some kind of Dan's the liar. Dan's not the liar there.
unique evil when they are pretty standard A-logs that you can
find in any large online community. Seriously, how's the treatment
that Ethan receives any worse than other lolcows like Wings of
Redemption, Boogie, Ethan Ralph, or Christian? Ethan himself
will even use subreddits like Trisha Paytas Snark, and Nick basically
runs a snark community against people like iDubbbz and Bowblax.
In reality, if Ethan would just disengage and stop fighting with
his detractor base, so many of his problems would go away. Ethan
is a nearly 40-year-old multimillionaire who routinely throws
himself into the line of fire by giving his takes on Israel.
I don't feel any sympathy for a middle-aged man constantly putting
himself and his family in this position simply due to the fact
that he is incapable of disengaging. Here's Diorio describing
this exact sentiment about
Are are these types, the ones that are that they don't belong
online, chat? Uh-oh. The Tipsters,
the Jaylens,
the
the peo- Dude, wait. How is
Maybe you know, we could say snark are different things. Has
Nicholas ever let Flamenco go? I I understand Flamenco keeps
going after him, too. But like, I feel like anytime Nicholas
could get a shot in on Flamenco, he does. That's been like forever.
That's like something I've always known about him. He will just
always take a shot at Flamenco whenever he possibly can.
And it's like, how is that not
the same [__] I don't know. It feels It feels very
similar. Like these people realized that once you get big enough,
you get like communities who dislike you, you get people who
like watch you and make fun of you, and they decided to like
moralize against that before they actually, you know, were underwater
from it. They decided to try to make some moral moral distinction
between what they used to do to larger creators, like when when
when Nick is watching H3 and he's calling E- Yeah, he's saying
Ela's horse-faced, right? Like he needs to differentiate that
from what's happening to him or Ela now. It's like they wanted
to get a jump on it. They knew it was going to come, and they
didn't like it, and so they got a jump on it to try to start
fighting against it preemptively.
Very bizarre.
People who have the lolcow gene.
The people who constantly
dive directly into the the spotlight
and just get farmed for weeks and weeks and weeks. Uh I mean,
you can You already know what they'd say? A whole bunch of totally
subjective things about how, well, it just happens more, and
it's like
It happens way more. You guys are like obsessed, and you're like
unhinged with the things you say. I never would have called CPS.
I never would have called CPS. You can give these people advice.
You can give Jaylen some advice.
You can give Flamenco a fireside chat. YOU CAN TELL TIPSTER,
"Just let it go." But they're never going to. Okay. They don't
They don't They can't They can't help them. You can't help them
because they're grown children. But for people like Tipster and
Flamenco who are already in their 30s approaching their 40s,
um at some point you just start not feeling bad anymore. If he
had any consistency, he would feel the same way about Ethan,
that he has the lolcow gene and is old enough to know better
than to keep poking the bear. But with Ethan, we have to keep
playing defense because of a CPS call that happened a year ago.
A call that never would have happened if Ethan had not revealed
very personal information about his children's health online.
No self-described commentary creator should be supportive in
any way of Ethan's blatant attacks on free speech. Ethan fans
and orbiters like Nick claim that he is only going after people
who were malicious in their attempt to infringe on his copyright.
That falls flat when he has previously described xQc as someone
who deliberately steals content with his lazy reactions. Take
it back, yeah. No, you're You still are a content thief, in my
opinion. >> Take it back, yeah. No, you Why would I take
it back? Because if you're going to reel back and say, "I want
I No, I just said that wasn't a good analytical point. I still
think you're a content thief. This would imply that xQc is also
malicious, and since he essentially freebooted Ethan's entire
video, wouldn't that qualify him for a lawsuit as well? It's
so obvious that Ethan is just weaponizing the legal system to
force apologetic statements out of his online enemies. These
lawsuits are fun I mean, only if if the copyright thing was his
primary goal, right? Which I mean, he stated that it was his
primary goal. Well, he He was the first thing he led with when
he went to make a video on it.
>> fundamentally built on lies, both regarding the legal
reasons for filing and the stated purpose behind targeting individual
creators. Ethan already settled with Keemstar and made her give
some strange ISIS beheading style apology that he lied about
and said it was genuine. I also think he's quite likely to win
against Frogan, as she also did a poor job reacting to his content
nuke. Denims' reaction, on the other hand, shows both the hypocrisy
of Nick and the lies Wait, maybe we got to give this junk drawer
guy some respect.
Is he making that claim about the Frogan thing because he actually
watched the Frogan thing? Or or what? Cuz like I I'll be real,
I don't know a single person who actually watched Frogan's reaction.
I don't know a single one.
I I can't I don't know any Usually every single person who talks
about this just "Yeah, I don't watch Frogan. Yeah, I just do
I don't watch Frogan. I don't watch I didn't watch Frogan. I
haven't seen Frogan's reaction. I don't know what it's like.
Yeah, I have no idea." >> job reacting to his content nuke.
Denims' reaction, on the other hand, shows both the hypocrisy
of Nick and the lies that he is willing to tell on Ethan's behalf.
Denims provided a substantially better reaction than both Keemstar
and Frogan. She even had a longer reaction to the content nuke
than Nicholas Diorio himself. Denims more than doubled the run
time of the video with her reaction and provided commentary throughout.
This is the same standard that was used to defend Chud Logic
against DarkViperAU when he filed a copyright strike for Chud's
reaction to his video. The community, Nick included, argued that
since Chud more than doubled the run time of the original video
with critical commentary, his video was not a market replacement
was fair use. When Denims clears these same markers, the goal
post shifts, and a new standard is created that all of her commentary
must be perfectly factual and relevant to the content that she's
reacting to. Nick says that her reaction was irrelevant and filled
with non-related commentary and moments of reminiscing about
past traumas. That means I added 120%
of the run time in commentary, on average pausing every 30 seconds
to add 36 seconds of commentary. Now, I'm not fact-checking this.
You're When you pause, it's never relevant. Coming from the guy
who goes on random tangents about complete every single second
of every single
Don't Hey hey You guys remember when this happened? Hey you guys
remember when that happened? Hey you guys remember when this
happened? Hey you guys remember when that happened? That's going
to be the criticism here, 100%. going to assume that she's telling
the truth here. I remember watching her video on my stream. You
can actually watch my reaction to Denims cuz I did react to her
viewing of it. And it was literally just like she'll go on a
random tangent about something that has nothing to do with the
video, or she'll hear Ethan say a sentence and then go on like,
"Remember this one time" kind of
Bro, there's no way he said, "Remember this one time." There's
no way he threw
Bro. If you've ever been in any kind of social situation with
Nick, you know that he does this all the time when
asked. It is like the thing he is totally infamous for. Like
Like literally every single person around him knows that if he
says, "Oh, this is like when You You have to stop it there, or
you are going on a like 45-minute tangent. And he's going to
be digging clips out to show you in
He is just commentary counterpoints when it comes to this [__]
He's like, "Oh, I've got an anecdote. Hold on. I've got a clip.
I've got TO WE GOT TO GO IN a different direction. Hold on."
So, despite that she's saying that, I don't think that she added
130 minutes of actual content to it, as much as she might have
paused and talked to chat or thanked somebody for something.
This is hilarious if you've ever watched a Nicholas Diorio reaction,
as his streams are full of irrelevant cutaways to MCU references
and memories of past traumas. I found several instances of this
when looking for clips for this video. What's the deal? >> That
sounds like some [__] in Family Guy. Peter Griffin's
like, "Yeah, it was Pearl Harbor. That's why That's why I come
out here and I fight the way that I do every single time." And
if they want Lois Griffin, it seems like you've been winning
a lot tonight. What What is your driving factor? Uh Peter already
told you the story about Pearl Harbor, right? Okay. Um well,
I guess for me
>> the ego is kind of crazy. Do you remember when you'd
be like, "Oh, what What What are they talking about here?" And
then EDP would be like, "Chris Tyson! Chris Tyson's looking at
Lolic Con. We need a bigger We need a better brand of influencers."
And it's like, "Dude, you're a
What are you talking about? Why are you calling out Chris Tyson
for Lolic Con?" And now here yeah, Mizkif is talking about why
the Stream Awards failed. Meaning what
>> He tried to tie it back in. How does that tie in? I
don't get Wait, how does that tie in? Lolic Con. Does that tie
in? And now here yeah, Mizkif is talking about why the Stream
Awards failed. Meaning what I have. Like I don't care to grow
too much. You know what's crazy? His whole life philosophy comes
from Tony Stark during Endgame. Keep what we have and get back
what we lost. Like that's literally Bowblax Bowblax's whole future
is designed by Tony Stark in
This one is okay. This is just a This is just a simile. It's
just a simile. It's just a comparison. He's just trying to make
a
Do you remember when That one is That one is fine. >> Tony
Zaret used TurboTax and tried to expose the government for like
threat like I guess like auditing him or something because he
didn't fill out the forms correctly.
And everyone's like, "Why dude? He's like a huge YouTuber making
millions of dollars and he couldn't hire an account he was too
cheap to hire an accountant and try and then like just try to
freeball it dude on himself like on his own [__]
It'd be the same. It's not the same. >> me like the Family
Guy [__] where Mr.
Mr. Puterships like Peter's making me do A A BIG BANG THEORY
WATCH PARTY WITH ALL THE GUYS IN the office. Now I do them regardless
cuz the show was really
>> He will be see. He now claims that Wow. He has changed
his content no longer watches full videos on stream but I hardly
see Do you think did he get audience captured into being unfunny?
I could have sworn Nick was funny. Nick used to be funny. Did
he get audience captured into being like
How did he get audience captured into like millennial humor?
I don't get it. He got audience captured into like dude, how
does that happen? See how that would save him some litigious
freak like Ethan or DarkViper determined that he did a bad reaction.
This is what happens when you he he made the wrong choice, okay?
He's making a lot of money so maybe it's maybe it's fine. Maybe
he made the right choice. This maximizes how much he could make
from content overall but like I feel like he was like the the
edgy guy. What happened to that guy? in one of their videos.
Denims losing this case could very well provide a legal precedent
that could be >> I remember the first time, okay? You want
to you want to talk about totally irrelevant stories and this
oh no, I won't. It's like one of the first times I hung out with
Nick in like a private VC but it's it's going to make him sound
really bad in a way that I don't want to. So I'm I'm not going
to tell the story. It was just he brought up some some content
that got a guy banned and it was just like it was edgy content
and we laughed our asses off watching this hyper edgy content
but I don't I want to make it seem like I'm trying to get him
like in trouble for it or something. So but it was like it was
funny cuz it was like it was hyper edgy stuff but I it's like
a completely different person now.
Like I can't imagine he would ever pull those clips up with anybody
now.
used against No, you got that's that's literally all you need
for the story. It's just like very different very edgy Ste Oreos
style of reaction. That reason alone should deter That's not
being funny. I'm saying that was funny though. It was funny.
him from blatantly supporting Ethan's attempts to ruin free speech
on the internet. Nicholas has also supported Ethan in the blatant
lies that he's perpetrated against Denims. Back in spring Ethan
used an edited and filtered video of Denims chat to push the
narrative that her entire community and live chat were calling
for Ethan to lose his kids and for someone to call CPS on him.
Well, it was apparently No, I think this is Well, [snorts] He
did he ran.
The Denims thing is the thing that will get him, okay? He ran
so much defense on the Denims [__] Dude, he ran so
much and then when he was dealing with even the slightest bit
of criticism from it, he was so dishonest with the way he dealt
with the
Dude, I hope man if Jontron had the
I feel like the best part of this and I didn't I don't know if
I saved this stream. It's probably on some some like Riles archive
or something somewhere but there was a stream where Augie comes
in and we show him this clip for the first time and he thought
this was the chat. He thought this was just the chat. And that's
everybody. Everybody thinks this is the chat that Denims is watching
and like not catching the messages in. That's why nobody believes
that she didn't see the messages because that's why Hutch argued
this against Pisco. It's why Destiny tried to make the same argument
against Pisco cuz every single person who watches this watches
that chat
and thinks that's the chat and nobody is willing to acknowledge
that. It's like there are light corrections from Ethan and I
think a correction from Nick but it doesn't matter like the damage
is done. You have to every time this clip comes up you have to
make it very clear that this was and you should probably have
something saying, hey there's a big deal that we totally like
kind of we sort of Denims over with this, okay? have made a a
good point. You said is this every [snorts] comment? I believe
this is a live feed of the chat. This isn't >> What about
the top right? I I thought these were >> No, it's this
[snorts] I think when you full screen it No, this isn't edited.
It's a cutout of the full chat. It's just enlarged there over
the screen, yeah. Here are the first
and last frames of the video that he played. I searched for the
top and the bottom messages in my Chatterino history. The first
one is line 14,472.
The second is 15,428.
And they're 5 minutes apart.
That's 956
messages in I By the way, real quick facts, okay? Denims didn't
do this. Denims didn't do this herself.
>> I hate to say it. Some simp did this, okay? Some simp
was trying to help Denims and do this for her, okay?
But also a lot of those messages genuinely take his kids from
him. These are two bad ones but there are ones in there that
aren't that bad.
in 5 minutes. He showed 65 messages which is less than 7% of
the messages from that time period. Nick nodded his head and
pushed this narrative ultimately placing responsibility on Denims
for the CPS >> statement about [clears throat] it and said
that she does not condone calling
>> So we're talking about CPS. One, I don't >> Yeah,
it doesn't mean she's not partially responsible for this occurring
by signal boosting this on a huge platform when you're astroturfed
by Hasan [__] who's using BadEmpanada as an attack
dog. No, I I need to use You know Nick is in trouble when he
has to use multiple
horrible names as amplification tools, right? Oh oh but like
huge platform Denims Hasan BadEmpanada BadEmpanada
Right? He's like doing a spell and he's like adding multiplication
like runes to this spell. He's like doing some Doctor Strange
casting a spell at somebody and he's like invoking the names
as he's casting to increase the power of the spell, right? It's
like dude, how about you just admit you don't really have a good
point here. Well, she's at least partially responsible.
Yeah, how much?
And that's the ultimate question. Don't don't ever forget that
that is the ultimate question.
How responsible is she?
You got a number that's over like 5% you're out of your mind.
And if you think she deserves, you know, her life ruined cuz
she's 5 By the way, you got a probably you have a number over
1% you're out of your mind but if you have a number over 5% you're
out of your mind and if it's less than 5%
why do you think her life should be ruined over it? Why?
These people are so dishonest with how they look at these things,
how they frame these things. It's obvious the reason they want
to do this is they want to make it clear that if you go after
Ethan Klein in any way, he's going to try to destroy your life.
That's what Destiny's doing. If you go after Destiny in any way,
I'm going to try to destroy your life and there used to be people
who do content on these kinds of people, okay? Unfortunately,
there are people like WillyMac and people like Nicholas
who seem
to feel no concern about any of the stuff that happens. They'll
just lie about it, let people lie about it. WillyMac finally
it took Destiny admitting to WillyMac that he had on his hard
drive for WillyMac to try to do something and then WillyMac basically
said, well, I might actually not make any more content on this
cuz I don't know what's happening. WillyMac has so
so little spine, so little sense of self that he basically got
bullied into going, well, actually I don't know if he really
admitted he had child I'm going to wait for the end of the case.
The case isn't about child anyway. I can't criticize Denims for
not pushing back hard enough on BadEmpanada in this reaction
but ultimately I do not place responsibility for the CPS call
on Denims. There's no evidence showing that she herself called
CPS and she multiple times stated that she disavows calling CPS
on Ethan. As of December 26, 2025 Nicholas still abides by the
principle that you are not responsible for every member of your
audience even if someone does an unhinged action. I'm sorry,
you can't police this. You cannot police an audience. The only
time you're responsible for your audience is if you spread misinformation
that causes them to go and harass somebody who didn't deserve
it. Like if you spread a false allegation of some kind and your
audience goes and clowns that person, that is your fault. You
have given them bad information. They have gone and acted on
that stuff um and now you are responsible but the expectation
that you can prevent crazy people from doing crazy [__]
that are statistically going to be watching you is absolutely
[__] insane.
The only solution to that is never criticizing anybody ever again
online and living in a padded cell. So even if the CPS call came
from one crazy Denims viewer, she's not ultimately responsible
for it. While she didn't have perfect coverage of the BadEmpanada
video, that doesn't make it right to lie about her and spread
deceptively edited clips to paint her as responsible for the
CPS lie. Nick refused to properly engage with this criticism
on multiple occasions. Originally stating on Twitter that the
only editing done to this clip was simply enlarging the chat
on screen to make it easier to read. Hand waving it away as a
snarker narrative and claiming that there was no context manipulation
at all despite again only displaying a heavily filtered selection
of chat messages. On stream the context of this clip came up
again and this time Nick didn't even give a take or opinion of
any kind. He just kind of trailed off and said that the objectively
correct narrative behind the context of this clip was stupid
and he found it funny. Um and and and No, Ethan you Oh, this
clip is so embarrassing.
This clip is so [__] embarrassing, dude. Listen to
it. He literally trails off like he's an old man and he like
loses his thought process. You don't understand. You manipulated
it. You manipulated it by showing messages on the screen alongside
[__]
so stupid, dude. The narrative behind that video is so funny
to me. Again and
Dude, just listen again to his his the accusation comes up that
basically the messages were manipulated to present a different
narrative like completely. Listen to his response. >> found
it funny. Um and and and No, Ethan you don't understand. You
manipulated it. You manipulated it by showing messages on the
screen alongside [__]
so stupid, dude. The narrative behind that video is so funny
to me. Listen, this happens to everybody. Sometimes you are talking
you like see a message, something happens. You lose your train
of thought mid sentence. Just say, I I my train of thought. Wait,
what? Hold on, I need to reset.
Why do you just like trail off? You create this clip of you just
totally sweeping with no basis for the sweep, right? No, Ethan,
you're bad cuz like you did something, you were dishonest.
So stupid, man. So stupid, man. Again. Lying is bad, Ethan. No,
stop lying, Ethan. Dude, it's so stupid, man. Another instance
of Nicholas not engaging in criticism when he knows that he's
wrong. Essentially, just downplaying potential criticism for
Ethan by hand waving the context away. Nick failed to address
this again when he reacted to iDubbz' content deputy on Ethan
Klein, stating that he knows that the chat was edited, but it
was just the timing of the chat on stream that was changed and
all of the messages were real and in context. It's one chat on
one stream
at different points to make it seem like someone is coordinating
an attack on you. Love uh >> made a a good point. You said,
"Is this Someone is literally co- Wait, what? What? at different
were real and in context. It's one chat on one stream
at different points to make
It's what? So the entire purpose of that clip is to make it seem
like it was insane for Denims not to take steps to protect Ethan.
If you misrepresent
that like basically people trying to figure that out. You're
making that claim with that clip. It was totally insane for her
to say she didn't see the messages or that she couldn't have
done something when her entire chat was filled with this message,
call CPS, take his kids away, call CPS, right? That is the premise
of that clip. You cannot create that premise with the clip if
you show the chat accurately. It doesn't
It obviously doesn't work. You were obviously lying when it was
presented. You've been lying the whole time. Just admit you were
lying or even just admit you were wrong. I don't need you to
admit you're lying even though you obviously were, but admit
you were wrong. It obviously was set up and edited to give a
certain impression
that cannot be reasonably defended. It's why we've watched multiple
people embarrass themselves trying to defend it in two weeks.
make it seem like someone is coor- Uh maybe like three or four
weeks now. I forget when the Pisco Huts combo was. >> dinating
an attack on Love >> uh made a a good point. You said,
"Is this Someone is literally coordinating an attack on him.
Absolutely.
What do we What do we call this? What do we call this again?
Oh, this is defensive lying? This is defensive context manipulation,
actually? They started manipulating first and this is like defensive.
I'm I'm defensively lying about Denims cuz if she doesn't get
her life ruined, um actually, they'll call CPS again.
Well, Nickly. And then he plays the clip where Ethan explicitly
tells you, "Okay, that they clipped the chat." And it's like
a cut out of it. >> chat. It's just enlarged there. >> Oh, really?
Over the screen, yeah. They're different, I think. Yeah. And
like it's it's It's Wait. Is that what happened? Or was Ethan
defending it again?
Hold on. Let me He said Ethan Ethan calls it out. Wait. Was Ethan
defending it again? Is that what was actually happening? Cuz
that's what it looked like.
Over the screen, yeah. They're different, I think. Yeah. So the
weird Swedish guy has to correct him and say they're different
chats. >> And like it's it's it's directly explained to
you in the stream what exactly this is.
IT'S OH! OH!
WE ALL CAUGHT THAT. ETHAN explicitly points it out and then someone
else points it out. It's stated explicitly on this stream that
it's not the same. No acknowledgement that he just immediately
went to full on sweeping for Ethan Klein without any knowledge
of what was going to happen. Right? We saw that. We all saw that.
I need to go back. I need to go back and do it again. Okay? Love
uh made a a good point. You said, "Is this Someone is literally
coordinating an attack on him. Absolutely. Unequivocally.
And then he plays the clip where Ethan explicitly tells you,
"Okay, that they clipped the chat." And it's like a cut out of
it.
Ethan explicitly calls it out. >> It's just enlarged there
over the >> Ethan is currently saying, "No, no, no, they're
the same thing." >> screen, yeah. They're different, I
think. Yeah. And like it's it's it's directly explained to you
in the stream what exactly this is. Who could take this seriously?
Who shows up for this night after night and they're just like,
"Yes, tell me why Hasan is bad and iDubbz is bad and Denims is
bad for the 900th night in a row. I need to know why these people
are all bad.
Nick, nobody but you could tell me how bad they are. I'm here
for you to tell me that they're really bad. They're really, really
bad. >> There's Like Love literally says it's not It's
not timed the same way. It's not timed the same way. Like all
of the context is in the clip. It's not It's not timed the same
way. Sounds so much better than actually we cut out all of the
normal commentary, which is the significant the not almost 95%
of it. So we cut out all the the good commentary, all of the
like normal chat messages, so it only seems like it's the bad
stuff. That's not timed similarly. Yeah.
Sounds bad. Sounds bad. Sounds bad.
Denims has confirmed in her own video that those messages did
come from her chat. There was never any contesting of the legitimacy
of these messages. The issue is that this is a tiny percentage
of the total chat messages sent during this time, and creators
like Ethan and Nick lied to portray it as the sentiment of Denims'
entire chat. There's only one other instance I could find of
Nick addressing this lie after How does this have 67 dislikes
already? How does this have 67 dislikes already? That's [__]
crazy. Where is Where is there a like um Where is there a disagreement
with any arguments presented here?
How do you disagree with any of the arguments presented here
on why Nick is like totally lying about the entire Ethan Klein
I Okay. >> In Ethan's response to the content deputy, he
outright admitted that this clip was edited and showed only a
small percentage of Denims' total chat. Nick conveniently did
not engage with this because he would have to take an L and instead
just started loudly reading his chat and didn't pay attention
to what Ethan was saying. >> Oh, so so so at first I made
that mistake. I genuinely thought >> Yeah. I want to point
out that Frogan is more mature and empathetic than Ian. She
I don't know. It depends. >> Here's that. Here's boo boo.
>> Like it's different ways. >> the the guy Keemstar
orbiter? But then soon after >> say though, yeah, I didn't
really see Frogan engage with that. It was more like every other
person than Frogan. I guess I can give Fro- Frogan the W there,
but Is he going to give Hasan the W there? It might just be because
she wasn't watched enough to see what she had to say about it.
He then went into a remember 2016 tangent before going back to
defending Ethan for spreading this lie, incorrectly stating that
he showed the full context of Denims' chat in the original clip.
The shameless lie that is immediately explained even in the clip
that Ian shows. Maybe Nick did just accidentally speak over the
context of these lies that he helped push, but I believe that
he still needs to expressly address these claims and acknowledge
that he pushed clips out of context to justify Ethan's continual
crash out over Hasan and his orbiters. Ultimately, 2025 has seen
the erosion of principles from Nick regarding Ethan Klein. He
went from one of his most prolific critics to excusing many of
the same behaviors that he once criticized Ethan for. Nick has
become Ethan's largest orbiter and will even outright lie about
other creators to benefit Ethan and profit from the situation.
There's now so much money and clout tied up in the situation
that actively taking a fair and balanced position would severely
impact Nick's revenue stream. It is simply not as profitable
or popular to take a nuanced position on these controversial
topics. Nick has seen tremendous success in 2025 by becoming
a Klein propagandist. He went from averaging close to 1,000 to
averaging around four or five thousand concurrent viewers. But
in order to do that, he had to sacrifice both his credibility
and long-standing
Yeah, I mean, that's
that's the exact criticism. That's the one. That's it. My biggest
cabal mindset
Oh, is this going to go into Oh, this is definitely going to
be Let me predict. Okay, I'm not going to scan even. I'm just
going to predict. This is going to be the Willy thing, right?
It's going to be Nicholas retweeting that Willy video where he
totally lies about the doxing [__] And then him just
like literally refusing to acknowledge any criticism that went
along with that.
criticisms of Nick are what I refer to as his cabal mindset.
Basically, his reluctance to properly criticize his close friends
and a sudden desire to shield and isolate himself from nearly
all criticism. This can mainly be seen in his coverage of the
commentator WillyMac Show throughout the course of the year.
WillyMac Show received a lot of criticism throughout the first
half of the year for how many feel he mishandled his coverage
on Destiny's criminal allegations and legal situation. Two of
the main critics of Willy were the streamers Queen and Jstark.
These two have spent extensive time covering and researching
every aspect of the Destiny allegations. So when WillyMac put
out what they believed was a poorly researched video, they were
quick to hop on a call with him and debate over the issues they
had with his coverage. Nick took great issue with this treatment
of Willy and even decided to debate AugieRFC over his treatment.
Nick was clearly By the way, a little thing in here that I always
point out but don't actually need um anyone else to care about
is I just offered to talk to Nick after this. I literally was
like, we I don't want to debate you. I'll just explain like,
"Hey, I I like said something wrong here." I literally was like,
"Hey, I'm willing to own a mistake I made." Which was like um
I wasn't even Oh, it was basically saying that you should have
like asked me about it or something, right? I was like, "Oh,
yeah, that was like a mistake. Here, we can just talk about it."
And Nick agreed to twice.
And then he refused.
He just like flipped. It was like, "Actually, I refuse to talk
to any of you guys."
Which is so weird. be very bothered about how Willy was treated
in this call, constantly making passive-aggressive remarks and
not fully understanding the points they were making in this debate.
Well, you talked about Destiny tonight. Have you talked about
all the Jstark approved talking points? Have you gone through
the list? What are the Jstark approved talking points? I don't
know. I didn't pay attention to them, but if you didn't include
them, you're sweeping. The criticism against WillyMac Show is,
you know, all dismissible. In fact, I agree with a lot of it,
honestly. Which criticism in particular? Cuz it was like I thought
the Queen one was a little stupid, but then I heard the Kelly
Jean one, and then I thought it was really
Okay, I'll tell you >> heard the J Star one and then I
thought it was completely I I thought it was indefensible. I
thought I thought all the streamer people are gay I thought the
video well no let me elaborate on my point. I thought the video
To briefly summarize Queen and J Star It's actually literally
everybody I interacted with I thought I thought this was all
like a thing where we were like trying to be honest with stuff
trying to like play to the facts and if you were wrong you just
owned it and move forward and I didn't realize that it was actually
just people running their own propaganda stuff.
Cuz one
I made
Why does wait why does Willie have his own docs information on
I he's literally got it in his own video. I guess he doesn't
care. I don't I kind of care um but like he Willie literally
conceded to me that he should have asked questions the the Kelly
left He literally said oh yeah yeah I should have done that.
Right? My whole problem with how people cover Destiny early on
like a big one was they just let him make assertions. They don't
ask him for any proof. Right? Hey he asserts this. It's like
cool did you ask him for any proof no no I did not just docs
Willie Mac.
Right? Augie Augie did completely roll Nick over in this debate
like embarrassingly so and then when I reacted to that debate
the only thing Willie took out of my reaction was when I referenced
the President Sunday infinite red machine referenced it and he's
like J Star thinks there's an infinite red machine. No well kind
of kind of the whole point of the infinite red machine isn't
that it allows infinite red to happen. It's like hey there's
a harmful person who's continuously engaging in harmful behavior
and there are people who are monetarily incentivized to protect
that person because they gain money from it.
The funny thing about the infinite red machine is it basically
got rebuilt and it's now it's the infinite doxing
We we he he turned the he took the destroyed infinite red machine
and he took the pieces and he added like a
and a 40k boomer and a person who got kicked in the head by a
horse and he turned it into the infinite doxing
It's crazy and then they're like oh you
didn't you guys docs people? No.
Is there any evidence of that? Well not that I've seen but like
I just it's too hard for me to look into it. Why are you why
are you talking about it and giving any like credence to what
he says then? Well he's like my friend and
>> talked with critical Willie Mac for priding himself
on talking to everyone involved in the Destiny situation but
not speaking to some of his main victims and not going in depth
enough on the main allegations himself. He spent half of the
video talking about how President Sunday and Beckett mishandled
the release of the Pixie story instead of nailing Destiny down
with better research talking points. For months Nick played up
the treatment that Willie received from this community pretending
as if he was beaten and lied or something. Nick kept making the
same lame talking point about Willie Mac being too much of a
normie to make good content. He's just a regular guy who doesn't
have time to worry about all this online stuff. Much for the
next hour? I don't know. You it's pretty easy to do the math.
It's two subs that's four subs four subs for another hour on
the stream. People go crazy when I say Willie's not like internet
people and he's not terminally online. He's just like some guy
who makes commentary videos and I don't think it's ever been
more obvious than like right now in this conversation. Ignore
him going 15 replies deep with Morale on Twitter or cutting off
his connections with Chud Logic over a minor joke at his expense.
He's just a normie that doesn't have time to properly research
his videos. Nick went as far as calling this criticism a gross
harassment campaign against Willie Mac instead of what it really
was criticism of a large creator who uploads poorly researched
videos that routinely get information wrong on complex topics.
Willie has been like a target of like a crazy harassment campaign
from like every other person online it feels like because he's
a normal guy who has normal guy takes
I again here's Nick putting his thumb on the scale right? Nick
obviously putting his thumb on the scale when he thinks Willie
Mac's in the right even though he's wrong about this. I'll give
it to him I'll say at least he thinks Willie Mac might be the
right okay? So he's putting his thumb on the scale. The second
Willie Mac makes a completely dishonest hit piece lying when
he's lying about me on Twitter he's lying about Queen in his
video Nick goes silent. Nick goes oh well I can't speak for this.
I'm out guys I what why would you expect me to comment on my
friend's I don't I don't do that. I'm not commenting on any of
this. Brother you spent the past six months commenting. You you
spent the past six months trying to put your thumb on the scale
for this and now he's just openly lied about a bunch of people
you used to hang out with and disassociated from. He just made
some [__] up and you're going oh well actually I
don't talk about this guys. I'm opting out. I'm out of this
Cool so cool.
I don't even want to say surface level but great introductory
videos for average people to watch on terminally online internet
drama
and there's just like this barrage of hatred this guy gets for
like absolutely no reason cuz he gets like minor things wrong
in videos occasionally which makes his entire backlog apparently
like the worst content ever. Actually Hold on. This is way better
than I so he did keep it he did keep the retweet up for quite
a while. Did he eventually take the retweet down?
Cuz that was the first criticism I made of him. Right? I was
like hey you obviously
need to take this tweet down. This lying video like you retweeted
this video that's obvious lies it's just completely made up no
no he's he didn't take it down. But did he actually eventually
take it down? It was only after a lot of pushing if I recall
correctly. Okay. All right. Cuz I do remember it was it I watched
or Did I watch the yeah I watched the video and then I commented
and then I noticed Nick still had the tweet up. I I think I went
through his Discord logs and he still had the tweet up. So let's
get this taken down. Let's hear what Nick has to say about calling
video criticism harassment.
Missy Missy Missy you don't even have to wonder if he knew about
the issues. I believe he had already commented on the issues
in his Discord before he took the tweet down. I think if I'm
not mistaken on the timeline I'm I I think so. ever. Actually
let's hear what Nick has to say about calling video criticism
harassment. Oh you've misreported Yes yes Hody Hody's got it.
Hody remembers the timeline. Let's go. Yeah I was positive that
he explicitly said I shouldn't have to I don't have to care about
this and I remember pulling it up on stream and going okay you
can say you don't have to care about it but you're literally
retweeting it and promoting it. Why are you promoting it if you're
not going if you you're promoting a video that you're saying
you don't have to comment on. That's objectively
by any standard. So I'm glad that Nick eventually caught wind
of the criticism my criticism at least and decided to take it
down. I'll say my criticism the obvious criticism okay? The obvious
criticism everybody would have. Hey why are you retweeting a
video and then saying well I don't have to comment on whether
it's truthful or not.
That's clearly moronic.
reported a story and gotten criticized for it. Hmm time to pull
the free speech card. Why why is it harassment to not like a
YouTube video? Why are you guys so [__] pathetic?
Nick has hung on to the No wait what is he wait what?
>> video criticism harassment. Oh you've misreported a
story and gotten criticized for it. No shot. Hmm time to pull
the free speech card. Why why is it harassment to not like a
YouTube video? Why No shot. What is this what is this video taken?
Dude this video is like
this video is like during the Noa Samson
the charity stream. This video is after.
>> Dude what?
Why are you guys so pathetic? Nick has hung on to this idea that
the anti-Destiny community as he calls them are so unhinged for
the ways that they demanded that he cover Destiny that it is
unreasonable to ever Wait I didn't demand that that Nick covers
them some way. I I didn't even I talked to Willie I think I messaged
him after that convo was like hey we could just chat about this
like it's I'm sorry I did I
That that was so light. That conversation with Willie was so
light.
I had
no idea he could feel so ass-blasted by just like a light convo.
I'll be honest though I also
>> I I just like gotten up that day and noticed that this
stream was happening and I was like oh could I ask him I just
want to ask him why he didn't cover like any of this stuff. Like
some of the threats and harassment and stuff. I think it's kind
of important. Right? And I might I might have pressed him too
hard possibly.
But I I didn't think it was like unforgivable.
I was totally willing to just go oh like let's just chat it up
let's chat. I don't want to fight with you guys. I thought I
thought it was crazy that that turned into like a massive fight.
I was like oh I just chat with you guys. >> or hear them
out or respond to But I didn't realize that it was the cabal
as this as his video is clearly laid out cleverly laid out. The
cabal mentality right? Oh this is somebody who's like going to
criticize us? No we got to we got to put them down okay? This
guy this guy thinks we could get something no we got to put these
guys down. And then he did this weird gay thing where he wouldn't
do it to Queen and cuz he was trying to like maintain friendship
with Chud and not totally I think he's trying to give Queen and
time to come around
and Queen was like no.
How many times did he go Queen is the last person I'm going to
be friends with. Queen and I like Queen and I like Queen and
but you know I thought he's a little over the line there. I like
Queen and but I like Queen and but and then Queen and just wouldn't
change his opinion and eventually after Nick you know trying
to give him you know holding out his hand to Queen and being
like come on man just join my side. He eventually just blocked
Queen and on everything. Yeah yeah yeah he what Nick was trying
to do
Here's the thing. Nick almost certainly had some base level criticisms
he was concerned about. I actually know for a fact he was concerned
about them from President Sunday. Okay? He was worried about
the criticisms from President Sunday and how they didn't look
good for him. Legitimately I'm telling you 100% fact.
I may or may not have logs to state this okay?
He was concerned about the Sunday criticisms and then there were
additional criticisms piling on after with Willy Mac. He got
worried about how that might all look. And so, he cut me right
off. That was pretty easy, okay? Which whatever, you can make
your decisions there.
But, he wanted to leave the Queenman thing open cuz he he like
Queenman, he was like thought Queenman was doing good content,
right? He wanted to leave that open. And I think I think it just
came down to again,
the criticisms wouldn't go away, Queenman wouldn't drop them.
And so, he decided to cut off just all people criticizing him.
And I guess to some extent like Chud,
I thought
I thought Chud tried really hard to stay neutral in all of that,
right? But, they are not looking for neutrality. Neutrality wasn't
good enough. And Chud was totally neutral for a very very very
long time. Chud was totally neutral.
And neutrality wasn't enough. I tried to stay neutral for a while
cuz I thought Nick was being absurd. I was just like, "Oh, he'll
realize like I won't go after Right? He he he'll realize he's
being absurd. I totally wanted to solve this like peacefully,
amicably.
And then around the time uh
I think I think at some point a video get done on on some of
the stuff that happened shortly after that. And
we'll see what people say. We'll see what they say. Big Brow
was going to do a video on this at one point, but we'll see if
other people are going to do videos. We'll see when it's all
said and done. any of their valid criticisms. He used this treatment
as an excuse to distance >> It's not ask me five years,
it's stuff everybody knows about that's public. I don't want
to bring it up. It's literally how they handled um
how they handled some like Cherry stuff
I thought was incredibly personal in a way that like wasn't called
for by anything I'd done.
And they did it explicitly to try to go after me.
Um I I haven't actually said it, I don't
Um when Cherry posted that she was
Willy Mac DM'd me laughing about it. I don't think I've said
that publicly before. But, he DM'd me to laugh about
And it was from that point on I'm like, "Oh, yeah, it's this
guy forever."
In a DM? Yeah, he was like, "Haha, how's it going over there,
buddy?" or something like that. And posted the tweet back at
me. I was "Bro, you you understand it's like it was it was like
really weird, okay? Um I could I could I think I've sent those
DMs to people before."
But, that was the one I I haven't even talked about it cuz honestly,
a lot of people just go, "Oh, that's based. That's funny." But,
I'm like, "Dude, that's psychotic."
That's psychotic.
Leak it?
Hold on. I just I I don't know where he could get the idea that
that was like cool given the other interactions, right? Oh, hold
on. I didn't get the like that it's him in the screenshot. Or
hold on, I'll clear out the rest of the DM. Only like the one
part. Hold on, I'll get it. I'll get it. I just And again, other
people be like, "Oh, that's based. That's funny." That's why
I never bothered leaking it cuz it's just the space, right?
But, uh
I could I could literally just leak the rest of this, but I'm
not going to. I don't even know what's said here. Walter. Yeah,
it was this.
This is July 3rd or something. Ugh, so how's go How's it going
over there? It's like, "Bro, are you serious?"
Are you Are you kidding me? Yeah, it's his DMs.
It's like it was so out of bounds.
It was like so insanely out of bounds. I think about like I can't
remember when his wet when this [__] happened with
his wedding. I think it was before this. Was it before this or
after this? I can't remember when the [__] was with
his
But like I ban people for the for like even referencing that
he got doxxed and his wedding got doxxed.
Any chance it's genuine? No. Go look at his tweets around the
time. Any chance it's genuine? No. 0% chance it's genuine. Did
you respond? No. Nope. Didn't respond. I'm trying to think of
if I had ever messaged him after that. I think I offered to squash
the beef at some point on Discord, but I don't know if I'll ever
be able to find those DMs.
I I can't imagine it was after. I thought it was before, but
not sure. What's this? Oh, this is Mizkif's contract or something.
Let's just go back to this video. I'm pretty sure that him and
his wife the thing with him and his wife was after, wasn't it?
Cuz I'm pretty sure
that I still tried to clean up like his doxx getting put out
there. Cuz that's how I am, man.
I'm just I'm just that kind of guy. He will jump scare it. Well,
it is it is how it is. Well, if it helps, you got offers from
his goat afterwards. It was
Yeah, he did. He did. Didn't he also refuse to um initially,
there was something like that, yeah. Well, uh
Yeah, Willy was just like totally deranged on this stuff in a
way that I wasn't. Like I would I would make fun of him, but
if he went and made fun of me, it's like, "What am I going to
do?" I'm not going to get mad at you for making fun of me.
Right? It's actually what it was pretty crazy. Yeah, I thought
it was like totally out of bounds personally.
I would have nuked him for that stuff. Well, what am I going
to do?
I think I think most people who see that I think most people
see that who aren't in this chat and are in commentary would
go, "Good, you deserve that."
So, it's like what why even complain about it? How you even going
to complain about it? Yeah, I don't know.
let's continue on with this fantastic Nicholas DeOrio video.
Willy waited until there was a formal complaint, right? I don't
know what you're talking >> And just for the ways that
they demanded that he cover Destiny, that it is unreasonable
to ever hear them out or
Uh yo, ADHD runs me. Thank you for the five gifted. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go. to any of their valid criticisms. He used
this distance himself from the Queenman and Jstark communities
that he once collaborated with. This distancing essentially led
to Nick entering his own fortress arc of sorts and no longer
participating in confrontational
Uh complaint filed through YouTube. Oh, yeah, I mean if other
people want to talk about that, I'm not going to I'm not going
to talk about that. It's not my thing to litigate, okay?
So, I'm trying to Like I I'm trying to just be respectful. I
don't want to
That was something that the Willy Mac DM was sent to me. I feel
like I can cover that. The other stuff is I think Cherry's handled
that how she wants to. She can handle that how she wants to.
I don't want to step in there. That's her thing to handle. Um
obviously I get frustrated Obviously, it upsets me, but it's
like not my thing to even go on stream and really make a big
deal out of, okay? Is my [__] not showing up? I got
the five subs and I put the timer in and I said thank you. Thank
you very much, ADHD runs me. I did see your Oh, maybe it didn't
show Maybe it didn't show up, I see.
Yeah, thank you so much for the gifted subs, ADHD runs me. and
or debates of any kind. Throughout 2024 and the beginning of
2025, Nick had occasionally collaborated with Queenman and would
even sometimes raid into his streams. I'm essential to Queenman.
Somebody reached out to me and they're like, "You should stop
going to Queenman because Queenman hates you, Nicholas DeOrio.
Queenman hates you. Queenman's chat hates you and you're like
a for rating him." It's like, "I like Queenman. Queenman is friends
with me. Um I I I don't care that he disagrees with me on certain
things. I have absolutely no problem with that that's happening.
I I think that if you're more
and so funny, okay?
I don't think Queenman really switched up that much. Queenman
maybe got a little more excessive in the same criticisms, okay?
In the things he would say. I don't think the core criticisms
really changed like from this point to when Nicholas blocked
him. I think the core criticisms were essentially the exact same
the whole time. or bent up about it than me, you probably wouldn't
be able to do very well in my position. You probably shouldn't
really give me advice about >> King to you? Listen,
if you're more upset about this than I am, then you know, you
shouldn't be in my position. You want to If you would just like
block this guy if you were in my position, then you wouldn't
be fit for my position.
Words spoken moments before disaster.
how to handle my friends. Now not interacting or acknowledging
this community is Nick's main strategic priority. When Nick cut
off his friendship with Aiden Underground over a minor DM leak
that wasn't even Aiden's fault, Nick went as far as saying, "My
chief concern Okay, okay, okay. Okay, I mean let's be real.
Aiden did trust Perry with his unlocked computer, okay?
That's [laughter] pretty crazy. concern above my friendship with
Aiden, yes, is that I'm not forced to address this [__]
to my stream or Discord chat. This is incredibly weak-minded
behavior from someone who criticizes others for a living. I have
a general principle that if you dish out criticism, you should
be at the bare minimum willing to take equal criticism in some
way. And also, I could see if Queenman was some absolutely insane
sperg with a minimal following like Mr. Sen, but Queenman is
a creator that Nick propped up through 2024 and early 2025. During
the Mutahar, Mama Max, and Bowblax dramas, he agreed with Queenman's
criticisms and even collaborated with him on some occasions.
But now that Queenman has criticisms of Nick and his terrible
he writes him off as some sort of obsessive Destiny anti-fan,
blocks him on all social media, and refuses to address him. Nick's
sweeping and isolation peaked over the summer when he outright
refused to cover Willy Mac's slanderous video, "Hassan and his
criminal friend doxxed and tried to ruin my wedding." In this
video, Willy outright lied about Queenman and Jstark running
doxxing communities and harboring audience members who doxxed
Willy and propagated information about his upcoming wedding on
Kiwi Farms. If you want to see more in-depth coverage of this
awful video, back in August, I posted a video that fully broke
down my issues with it. To briefly summarize, Willy presented
no evidence at all to back up these claims, and it was even revealed
that this information was given to him directly by Destiny. At
the time, Destiny was trying to frame Jstark and Queenman as
doxxers.
Oh, by the way, we should always maintain We need to archive
what Destiny's precise allegations were as times as time has
gone on because it's changed and it's changed and it's changed.
And when he goes to write his manifesto that he said he was going
to write tonight, when he goes to write that manifesto, the allegation
will change, okay?
He's going to say, "Oh, well, uh all these people harassed. They
they they harassed. They
they doxxed." That was the big one. They doxxed my friends.
They doxxed my friends. No, we need evidence of that, okay? We
need evidence of that.
Show me the evidence of that that led to your doxxing campaign,
Destiny. That's what you got to do. That's the bar.
Like his friend Rose, who he doxxed? Yeah, I guess so. This was
so he could have justification to dox them and their communities
as some sort of self-defense doxxing. I will dox if I have the
opportunity to. Doobie should get his getting posted if I get
it in my hands on it, 100%. For Anna, like I legitimately if
you Yeah. >> What is Doobie's sin? Being in the in cahoots
with all these weirdo A-loggers that are obsessively talking
about me, talking about me to every other person, and doing this
weird pressure game in the background. Anybody that's part The
weird pressure game in the background. What happens is Destiny
posts some doxx and I just go, "Hey, hope you're aware of this.
Hey, I hope you're aware of this." I send it to like three people.
Connor's one of them. Con- Connor is literally one of them. I'm
like, "Hey, look, he's doxxing somebody again." That's That's
basically I'm just like, "I want you to be aware of this. I want
you to be aware of this. Look, he's doxxing somebody again. Look,
he's doxxing somebody again."
That's not obsessive. It takes me 5 seconds it when you dox somebody
like once a week.
If you were to think I deserve to be doxxed in return for that,
well, that's kind of crazy, but >> part of like those communities
in my mind, it's all Hamas to me. Willy, being the [__]
that he is, played right into this narrative by doing no fact-checking
and just running with Destiny's talking points. When members
of the commentary community had serious issues with this video
such bold claims and presenting literally zero evidence, Nick
did very briefly address this on stream. He talked about it for
3 minutes total before he claimed that it was gay interpersonal
community drama and only spoke about the video one other time
in his Discord. >> Now, uh why about probably six of you
are in the stream, I just wanted to briefly talk about this Willy
Mac Show drama. Uh I I made it pretty clear that I didn't really
want to do the interpersonal drama show a couple of weeks ago
and up until this point, I've probably done as much of that as
I possibly could. I told Willy, "Don't I told Willy not to talk
to these guys."
I'll just say I told Willy Mac Show that he should just drop
this and he should
he should just leave he should just stop fighting with these
people and in retaliation, a video came out talking all about
these people. So, at that point, there's really not much I can
say or do. I I I gave him my opinion. He did the opposite. So,
now I think that him and Augie are going to fight a lot and I
am I'm I'm rooting for
Oh, man, hold on. >> you to get as much content as you
want out of it. And at this point, my understanding of how this
is going to move forward from here is I think that everyone's
just going to be awful. >> It doesn't really seem like
anybody is moving into this discussion looking to have a um a
beautiful, productive dialogue. It just seems like from here
everybody's going to start side-swiping each other.
So, I don't know if I watched it at the time. I could easily
have a productive dialogue about this, but it's going to involve
really, really, really rough stuff. Like asking for any evidence
you have to support any of the things you said. That's like baseline
stakes for the conversation, right? Bring whatever evidence you
have for the [__] you said.
Unfortunately for Willy, the [__] he had to to justify
what he was saying was one guy in ChudLogic's Discord who posted
one picture that I believe I can't remember if it was or wasn't
of Willy's wife.
Okay, the Spencer guy. That's like the one thing they had was
some random guy posted that in Chud's Discord and then got banned
immediately.
Or almost immediately after a couple hours or something. I think
it got removed and then he got banned eventually once it got
to the mods. Evidence, those days are over, man. Dude, it's it's
just wild. >> Listen, I've had to put multiple friends
down over the years. You guys gather around every every summer
to watch Nicholas DeOrio come through and another friend so you
can tell me off for the next 6 months about what a huge piece
of [__] backstabber I am up until the point where
the next friend says two words out of line and all of a sudden
it's banging down the door to go make me talk about it again.
Uh I think the commentary community can probably handle this
one of their own.
>> I wish you both luck in your forever war. Nick has outright
admitted in his Discord that this video was bad, but never acknowledged
that Willy outright lied in his coverage and has not made any
effort to retract his claims or provide proof. Nick has continued
to support Willy since the release of this video. He's watched
his client propaganda videos on stream and endorsed several pieces
of his content. Any other commentator would be torn to shreds
for releasing a video like this, but because Willy is in Nick's
in-group, he gets a pass and will never be properly pressed for
this video. Nick was always the guy who was willing to call out
his friends and even burn bridges when he felt like someone was
up to a serious degree. Nick spent basically all of 2023 and
2024 ripping into people like Tipster and
He doxxed. Hold on. We got a five gifted from Marty Epstein.
Let's go. Thank you very much, Marty Epstein. Appreciate it,
buddy. Appreciate you. Nick has taken the not-so-honorable
track, okay? In terms of solving this problem. Nick DeOrio has
decided to go, "Actually, these guys were mean to me, so I don't
care about anything done to them. They were like mean to me,
so now I don't have principles cuz these guys were mean. They
watched a video of me eating cake and that was rude. They laughed
at it. They laughed at me eating cake. I will never ever defend
anyone who laughs at me eating cake laughs at me eating cake,
okay? It's [__] up. So, what exactly did Tipster
and Bowblax do compared to Willy? Bowblax lied to Nick personally
about his mental health diagnosis and publicly lied about Nick
running the Content Cop Twitter page. He's a total loser who
deserves to be called out for this behavior, but I would still
say this is less egregious than Willy lying because commentators
like Nick called out these lies and Bowblax is a widely mocked
figure that nobody takes seriously. Tipster was too eager to
defend the wrong people and ended up making poor defenses for
content in multiple instances. I don't think Tipster's pro-Lolly,
he just defended like three people who were involved in controversies
within a 1-year timeframe and then ended up looking very suspicious.
In terms of commentary, he publicly cut ties with the community
and would very performatively talk about how toxic everybody
was. He was very well within his right to leave, but he did so
in a very un- I can't imagine somebody who had cut ties with
a commentary community, a community of commentators,
And then publicly disavow and move away, just turn into a total
like soy I can't imagine. Could you imagine a rotund man doing
such a thing? I can't imagine it.
I can't imagine it. Defending some fairly indefensible content
repeatedly, disavowing a community of commentators,
lying about them, okay? Supporting people who lie about them.
I can't imagine someone doing that. It's a good good thing
Wait, who's Tipster? I'm talking about the guy in the the guy
who's the subject of the video. Who's Tip- I don't even know
anything about Tipster. noxious and unsuccessful way. In reality,
as Tommy C describes it, Nick hated Tipster so much because he
broke his heart by leaving the community the way that he did.
Probably less Nick than any of them.
And I think Nick targeted you for years for wreath because you
broke his heart. And he's not going to say that, but I If Nick
was so willing to cut off Tipster and Bowblax for these misdeeds,
you would assume that he did not actively prop up and promote
a creator who still has a video on his channel with over 200,000
views where he is smearing the reputations of several small creators.
As of December 2025, Nick is still watching Willy's H3H3 slot
videos on stream and sending people to check out his channel
where they can easily find this video that is full of lies and
misinformation. Nick has also historically been willing to call
out commentary creators who have made terrible videos that are
either full of lies or blatantly dishonest, even those that he
considered friends. Nick entered a years-long feud with Technicals
over his awful coverage of the Zero situation in which he lied
and mischaracterized the narrative surrounding a his 20-personal
feud over his enemies. Before this, these two were friends frequently
collaborating on videos and appearing on streams together. While
I do have serious issues with Nick's coverage of Zap Tie that
I might get into another time, I do believe that he was generally
in the right to call out the sweeping for Zero and I do believe
that Zero was much worse than Zap Tie. Nick also spent a large
portion of 2024 calling out King of Nothing for slandering Ethan
Klein in one of his videos, even going as far as saying the video
was borderline defamation and saying that anything less than
a full video removal should be kindly ignored and remembered
upon King of Nothing's next upload. King of Nothing at least
tried to show evidence of Ethan Klein being an NFT scammer despite
how poor that evidence actually was. Willy Mac never showed any
evidence of Queen and J Stalk running doxxing communities and
is a significantly larger creator, making it much more difficult
for these smaller channels to correct the record about how Willy
was lying. So, in the past, Nick would proudly jump in to call
out and heavily criticize these terrible creators. Nick has always
made a big deal about self-policing your community to root out
bad actors. Yeah, I mean, the perfect place to hang out if you
want to be never questioned on anything, right? Is to hang out
in a place that doesn't self-police and Hasan's community and
that sector of like far-left tanky adjacent people, there's no
self-policing because they can't find anyone who wants to like
like nobody wants to make content with them. They're all kind
of trapped in their own little bubble and they're just comfortable
lying to you. But when one of his friends decide to put out a
slanderous hit piece, Nick declares the drama too gay and interpersonal
and refuses to properly engage with it. I'm not even saying that
Nick needs to completely cut off and end his friendship with
Willy, but it should be the expectation in the commentary space
that if a large creator makes a very poor video, other creators
should be willing to call out and publicly correct the record,
especially if this creator is someone that you constantly promote
and associate with. It seems that in his year-long quest to become
an H3H3 orbiter, Nick has forgotten these standards and principles
that he once had. 2025 has seen a great many changes for Nick.
Downfall's been crazy, but the downfall's like an upswing for
Nick, right? Nick's making more money than he ever has. He's
making He's got to be making at least 20-30 grand a month, you'd
think, right? At minimum? 20-30 grand a month streaming?
I think so. >> It has seen him abandon most of his principles
to chase a very lucrative new audience that he will gladly push
straight-up lies for. Nick no longer cares about the quality
of his coverage, self-policing his community, or listening to
criticism of any kind. Instead, he would rather rake in tremendous
amounts of money and try to rock the boat as minimally as possible.
I for one hope that in 2026 the general audience will start to
see the lies that the clients and their orbiters have pushed
and will be more acceptable to have a nuanced position on the
never-ending war between Ethan Hassan and Destiny. Hopefully
in the new year Nick can re-evaluate some of his principles and
actually address some of the major criticisms that have been
levied against him. But with just how successful his biased coverage
has been, that ultimately seems unlikely. Thank you to anyone
who watched this all the way through. Your support means a lot.
Make sure to subscribe, leave a like, and follow me on Twitter
or Instagram. My accounts are on the screen. Or if you want to
join my Discord, that's linked
I'm going to link the channel. I'm actually going to link the
video. You guys should go subscribe to the channel. Channel did
a great job on this video.
I thought you all did a great job. It's a good video. First pinned.
Hold on.
Follow Oh, hold on. Why did that not